in one of your sermons you said that
the devil this is the devil's world
could you explain
that a little bit yes let's pray again
father as i continue
answering questions for your beloved
people continue to grant wisdom to the
pastor and me in jesus name i pray
amen the temptations of christ are found
in two places matthew 4 and luke 4.
in matthew 4 is eat turn stones to bread
jump off the building
worship me in luke it is turn stones to
bread worship me
jump off the building now in luke's
version luke chapter 4 verse 6
and the devil said unto him all this
power will i give thee and the glory of
them
for that is delivered unto me and to
whomsoever i will i give it satan is
saying
all this was given to me when when adam
sinned
are you with me now when jesus died he
bought it back
but it's not yet in his control are you
with me christ
legally bought the world back the reason
why satan went up to heaven
in job 1 verse 6 now there was a day
when the sons of god came to present
themselves before the lord
and satan came also among them he came
to represent the earth and the lord said
unto sin whence came us thou
then satan answered the lord and said
from going to and fro
in the earth and from walking up and
down in it
symbolizing that's mine because when god
promised canaan to mock to abraham he
told him in genesis
13 verse 16 arise walk through the land
in the length of it and in the breath of
it so god told abraham to do
exactly what satan said he was doing
expressing possession
and so in a certain sense this is the
devil's world
in john chapter 14 verse 30 jesus said
the prince of this world cometh
the word prince the greek word arkhan
means a ruler and has nothing in me
second corinthians 4 4 paul says the god
of this world have blinded the minds
and so yes in a practical sense the
devil this is the devil's world
but christ has brought it back legally
but the devil is still squatting
along with his people and christ is
coming to remove the squatters
do not be among them get to christ when
you're with christ
you are legally inhabiting the world
you're not squatting
all right let's let's just have a
follow-up to that yes if you don't mind
okay
oh follow up okay uh pastor so
in a sense god made an exception in
allowing satan into that meeting
because we know that sin cannot exist in
the presence of a holy god
that was the question that the pastors
are looting no no satan did not stand in
the full presence of god remember
that uh jesus is the lamb slain from the
foundation of the world
are you following me the administrator
of the universe is the creator
that's christ the same with the blood of
christ was effective from the foundation
of the world
so was his humanity so anyone coming you
see you can't have bloodshed without
humanity
i don't want to be deep or tough think
abraham was saved by the blood of christ
before it was shed are you with me noah
by the blood of christ well
it means the humanity of christ had to
be effective for his blood to be
effective
because the spirit can't bleed are you
with me
and so because of christ he could come
but he couldn't come into the full
presence of the father
through christ he could come up to
heaven
and we don't know exactly where in
heaven he was you see all right
thank you okay all right
you